فاجئ ابنتي بشيء
كانت تريده لفترة طويلة
[موسيقى]
اعتقدت أنها كانت مجرد متعة عبر الإنترنت مثل
يوميات ابنتي والأنشطة
التي سأتمكن من عرضها لهم يومًا ما
مثل الأشياء الممتعة التي قمنا بها  طفولتك
وأعتقد أن الأمر أبسط مما تعتقد أنه
عليك فقط بذل جهد للقيام
بذلك وهو الشيء الأكثر مكافأة
في العالم
أنك لن تحصل عليه،
لا أعلم أنه يجب عليك القفز ورميها
جاهزة  لذلك كان على ابنتي أن تذهب إلى
الطبيب، ثم في ذلك اليوم، وكانت
حزينة عندما عدنا إلى
المدرسة، فشعرت وكأنني سأملأ الظفر
بالكرات وأفاجئها
ثم عندما دخلت في ذلك  مقطع فيديو
تشاركه وهي تقول مقطعًا
لهذا السبب فعلت ذلك
وبأحلى صوت يبدو وكأنه
جعلني أبكي تقريبًا هناك تحبه
ولا ترى مثل الضعف والأنوثة
من رجل وابنته
أعتقد أن قطتنا  كان مشجعًا للآباء
والبنات أن يحبوا أنه يمكنك القيام
بهذه الأشياء مع ابنتك والتي لا يمكنك
التواصل معها في تلك المستويات
[موسيقى]